I'm just testing if I'm on hold on hold on this is the dumbest idea over where I'm at
hold on hold on hold on this is a nightmare hello I'm opening my own stream up on my phone
one second strong calls hello can you hear me hold on I need to actually watch more stream
I'm so sorry about that oh that's me oh you can tell I'm in the bathroom okay ain't no filler
okay so to put it lightly I'm broadcasting
um and uh I'm gonna get in the back because it's already here I don't know if you can hear this
oh it's burning hot lovely um okay I need to put that this thing where it takes this is so hard
and you put a little more cold water in the bathroom I'm gonna burn myself hold on
oh no that's so loud
one second
and it's so loud
okay I think I'll do it I'm just gonna burn myself it's like
oh
can you hear it
hold on oh I need to put that on the ASMR so you're currently on a tripod right now
can you hear it? I'm tapping your ears okay you're on a tripod
I'm the man there's also bubbles I'm with bubbles
okay I'm thinking really really really don't say such things the peeler allegations are gonna end this stream
right look I've got some bubbles ready I'm gonna put them right on your ear
you can hear the bubbles pop I'll put them on your other ear as well
these bubbles are in the same holder as moment
thank you everyone who has subscribed and helped me get to 10,000 subscribers
because now I'm going to do really silly ASMR like this
the make is static
the right ear is really messed up
let me get out of this bath
random static on the ear
don't say that panic hold on let me get out of the bath
random static are you sure it's not the bubbles
right ear static it's very set up for fuck sake hold on let me get a towel
I can't get out of the bath already the stream isn't starting
random static why the fuck would there be random static identify yourself right now
hold on I'm getting out of the bath
hold on the streamer is right next to my bathroom okay
one second I'm gonna go to another room
okay I'll verify
why are you static
I'm poking a poke at a snake yet
trailing water all through
is the static gone
is the static
it's probably the bubbles
make sure the bubbles off your ear
make it confusing here
I'm taking the bubbles off your ear
I swear if that's what the static is you make me get out of the damn thing
hold on static sound is gone
okay we're going back in the bath boys
okay we're getting
okay we're in the bath
hi
okay we're really in the bath this time
well we were before but now we can actually try
are you squinting me right now
are we on a tripod
yes I am a tripod you are
I will say thank you to everyone at the end of the stream because I cannot see anything in this current set up
okay since we're okay
okay I'm back
but as I was saying thank you for 10,000 subscribers
this is a special stream to thank you for
I literally
I don't know what you would like me to do
do you want me to soap you down
should I soap down
I mean shoot
I'm going to move the tripod over a little bit
and then
okay I'm going to give you kisses while I'm in the bath
spit
oh splat okay
you want to soap me down
I don't know have you built
I literally have all my A smart children's
do you need this
oh yeah
you like that
sorry about the face tracking
but we're in the bath
you want sponge cleaning
does that mean my ass
this is a tanky celebration
give me a tank
I mean
if you subscribe I'll leak
a future stream
oh god my pc's
oh not my pc
it's about to take off
what would you like me to do
oh and water
are you ready
I have like a little spray bottle
I can spray it everywhere
because it's just me in the bath
it doesn't sound very ASMR
I'm going to be honest
it sounds pretty shit
okay I clean your ears I go breathe
oh yeah
but by the leaks
that was my hippo born of year
at 15,000 subscribers
I'm going to do it in real life
that I can't ASMR
so I just thought you should know
so thank you everyone
don't be
I can't reach
my tongue can't reach
it's a squirt gun
thank you
let's go
I've already passed 15,000
oh god that's right
what are we doing for 20,000 subscribers
what do you want
do you want to show or I'll do a show
I'm taking my bath
can't speak for long unfortunately
thank you for the ASMR mama
I'll redone the donations and tips at the end
in the membership's okay
I just can't
sorry I'm squeaking a boat in this bath right now
hello
they can't push me squirtin
I'm not squirtin
okay let me pretend to do real ASMR
okay
I'm going to brush your ears
over in the bathtub
with me
and then I'm going to look after you
and I'm going to get you
all nice
and clean
and pristine
actually if I move the tripod over here
is the face tracking going to work a bit better
I'm trying to move above this bath
without doing that
rub-dub-dub
reef links in the top
and a clean clean clean
and I'm going to make it pristine
can you hear all the bubbles in the background
I wonder if the microphone's backing up
or not
do you like bath time with Stourney
be honest
we're no longer a pheromone maxing
we're cleaning up
do you hear me
can you hear me young man
no more pheromone maxing for you
you're getting clean
and I'm going to do it to you
and you're going to say thank you
yes I think you can hear the bubbles
you want a mud bath
right to make me gay
you should hear me
okay so this is a dirty sponge
okay
you can hear this dry
so I'm going to put it over your ear
and then we're going to get the sponge away
and Stourney's going to clean you
okay
and you're going to sit there
like a good little reef
like and take it
do you like my bubbles
huh
okay now we're going to get it wet
are you ready to get it wet
okay
okay all right now
okay I'm going to squeeze it
I don't know if you need me to squeeze
not squeeze
squeeze squeeze squeeze squeeze
because I don't want too much wetness on the ears
Stourney isn't I don't trust you
but I'm having to hear a good girl
rather do you want me to soap up
does that sound wet
when I brush it over your ear
because the sponge is all wet
I'll get you all nice and clean
yeah you want me to
a light guard
sure this is a bathtub
maybe this is a bathtub
yeah
okay you want me to soap up
I'll soap up
reeflings
I know you're not used to this
with other streamers
but I can do whatever you want me to do
okay
you're in control
so tell me what to do
okay
for this cuttlefish to smell like lemon
do you hear this
that's my soap bar
can we eat the soap
reefing
right
I'm going to sit on my butt
because I was sitting on my feet
even in the bath
I'm gonna get the bar soap wet
and then we'll start with my feet
and then
work our way all the way up the body
deal
so I'm putting soap all over my feet
and my legs right now
or my pre-legs
I don't know what you can hear
so you take the soap bar
and you do it on top of the feet
and then you can even use
your finger in between
actually here's my feet
at the side of the mic
okay
can you hear my foot again
all soaked up
that's my feet
see
you can use your hands
but I'm going to get
a cloth
are you ready
the reason
you use a cloth
can you
did you hear my stomach
the reason
you use a cloth
is because
I feel replaying
it exfoliates the skin
10,000 years of green beans
you're done
okay
are you sweating here
this screen really isn't
that different from your normal streams
considering you said you usually stream
with basically nothing on
you're just in the bath this time
the stream isn't any different
because you never show your clothes on
you're untrue
okay so that's the bottom of my feet
and then for the top of my feet
I'm doing both feet at the same time
one
and now
I'm doing my little legs
the four legs
are you squidding me right now
TTS on three
does Brian have a 3D o2
okay
I know a little replaying
it's time for my thighs
so we're putting soap all over
my thighs right now
getting them all
laying on them
and then
it's scrubbing
to get all the dead skin off
okay
over here
like to go to a sauna with me
okay and then you can scrub my back
and I'll scrub you
with the off
there you go
and now
replaying
I'm going to go on my knees
because
I need to clean
the peach and the clam
next
oopsie
that was loud
so you put a little bit of
soap
on the cloth
and you can put the soap on
you get it all
soapy
there now it's all soapy
and then clean
all around
and you do your peach too
you need to do your turquoise
please be careful
wait why don't you be careful
you're fucking going to come through the window what's going on
she's getting lunch ready
replaying
the walls
okay
so now that
the peach and the clam
are spotless
we get to the tummy tank
does reefing want to clean
my tummy for me
or will I do it
and make you watch
wow
my frickin' pee scene just
oops hold on
my screen just went black
that means the stream is dead or not
okay I'm still here
that was scary
please don't do that again
mister laptop that terrified me
okay I'm still here
let me put some soap on my belly
isn't that an awesome power school
put some soap on my belly
tummy time
okay you're still alive
okay I'm squeezing out the
extra liquid
and then I'm scrubbing my tummy
scrub scrub scrub
all in the tummy
and then after the tummy
you can go up higher
don't worry
are you going to marry me
to the coconuts
by the egg stream
clean body on
scratch scratch scratch
when you exfoliate
and you scrub all the dead skin away
your new skin is all nice
and healthy
that makes sense
where is my bar of soap I've lost already
oh there it is
okay
okay and then
you do your armpits
because we already did the coconuts
I don't know what to call them
but you do your armpits next
and the reason
why you can't just keep putting deodorant
on top of deodorant
is because you need to remove
your stank
if you didn't know
body odor
is because of
I think it's the bacteria
and you need to get rid of the bacteria
because it's stinky
so you need to wash your pits lots
does it tickle when I wash
your pits
I'm supposed to close the top down
wait do you guys go top down
I go bottom up
am I doing it the wrong way
am I being body washing
right now
am I supposed to be top down
it's always top down
even in a bath
okay well this thing
will be enforced
to get
cleaned
you're getting cleaned
the bottom to top
okay
because the most important thing about it
is that the bottom
okay
in the shower
I would do top to bottom
but in a bath I think it's bottom to top
alright I just need to make sure
you're clean okay
one second
does it tickle
when you have someone else's cleaning
yeah
that's okay if you like to tickle
okay I think you look nice and clean
but definitely
need to water you down
okay
you want a homemade slime
you know
a homemade slime with stream
do you like the sound of the water
tickling
I think it's relaxing
but I need to take the soup off of you
now okay
so let me just
let me take all off of you
okay
and then your other thing
we're taking a little
of more soap
because you're all squeaky clean
because you're so small and you're fine
I feel like bath time
well mommy
let's take a look
okay
I'm gonna wipe the soap off my
one bits
because I have soap on my one bits
I'm taking it off
and then for
your arms
or your tentacle
because you've got eight little, you've got eight arms
not these legs
for the arms
you do the exact same thing darling
put a little soap on your exfoliating thing
which is a cloth
or it could be something I don't know
I don't think that far ahead
and then just start with your hands
and then work the way up the arm
and that's not enough
so pour water
no I'm not cleaning your third leg right now
that one time I was reincarnated
as mommy's bath war
that's terrible
so that's my right arm
well done
the way now you're washing the brain
I don't have enough brain to wash
my brain is like a
chicken thigh or something
it's so smooth
the worst part is trying to do your back
it's fucking impossible
now we're trying to do my back
but briefly I know
that you're really short and you can't reach
but my goodness I wish you could reach right now
because I can't do my back of my arm
I have a problem
with my shoulders where I can't
put them like my arms back by
my head too far because I have damage
to one of my shoulders
it's actually a bad one
starting the bath water bit
you guys are not bidding
over the bath water
I am not shipping this out
this is a bi-wizard
I assure you
my bath water is a literal bi-wizard
congrats on telepathy
I think I'm probably doing this
for a brush
it wouldn't make it past customs
you could probably make more
selling what's left of the lemon soap
do you like when the cuttlefish
smells of lemon?
the customs officer would drink it
please do not drink my bath water
if I was ever crazy enough to sell you
my bath water
I give my face a little wash too
I'm not going to use soap
because if I get it in my eye
I'm going to cry
just scrub your face
and your neck a little bit
and behind your ears
don't forget behind your ears
speaking of forgetting
behind your ears
I forgot to do behind your ears
this is just behind your ears
I'm from
one
I keep forgetting
to look after you
but not in a sense that I forget
I mean, I'm trying to scrub myself
so
sorry my hand farted on the bath
I scrub a little bit
there you go, now the back of your ears are all clean
now show me your belly button
so I'm going to
fucking
put soap in your belly button
and scrub it, okay
you put soap in your belly button
I need it, I like it
I need to do it
because the belly button is like a germ trap
okay
how could you get the mic into me?
I don't
the microphone is connected by 10 meter cables
I shit you
that was not a fart by the way
that was the cloth before
I'll take the soap bath for $100
jokes aside
congrats on 10k subs
here's to a minute
I'll take the bar
soap for $100
oh wait, I can see the messages a little bit
but I'll go back and read the other message
someone bet $20 on the bath
no one is going to send this fucking
I swear God, if you guys make me
send you this fucking bath water
I'm so annoyed
I have
seed jars that I could in theory
put them in but I'm sure the water
would like, I don't know, customs wouldn't allow that
how much prep time did this stream take?
a lot
I was up an hour and a half
I go, oh god it's a freaking
laptop, it's gonna sleep
I'm currently on a laptop
removing into my PC
with a 10 meter
set up on a 3DO
that's on a tripod and my face
tracking is also on a tripod
but because I'm lower down
in the bathtub and the stand up
that iPhone goes on, it can hardly see me
this was a lot
in the making, the 15k
thai smart is going to be a lot easier
to produce
don't have any games or
stuff, oh I can brush
your hair I feel like
I have a brush here
brush, brush, brush
while I'm in the bath
I have a brush here
oh you can't really pour that much
unless you move around
mmm
I have a brush here
brush, brush, brush
small mommy
I mean a little baby
I'm not very tall
you're already on your way to 20k
I don't know what to do for 20k subscribers
I don't know what yous want
I mean unless you want shower
then that's fine, I can do shower easy
basically
I was gonna finish that
and then I was gonna oil up
and then that would be the stream
that you get to listen to me oil up
and keep my skin all nice and smooth
and soft for you
and it helps your tent
cause run over my skin
so yeah
and of course it's coconut oil
so what's the price mommy
there's no price I'm presenting bath water
that's so gross
and one a years I'll be like
one a years I'll post on twitter
and you'll be like I drank mommy's bath water
here's a video and then everyone will be like
oh my god that's her seat jars
that refill really did
exercise ASMR
unfortunately
I think heavy breathing
I don't know
maybe exercise ASMR could work
ring for ASMR and then bath after
ooh
I actually like that idea
we do ring for ASMR
so try and be as quiet as possible
I still know the fucking workouts
and then afterwards
we go into the shower how does that sound
I think we can do that
that sounds fun for 20k
someone cook there
yeah
I'm brushing all your hair
even though you're bald
theoretically cause you're
a cephalopod
quiet ring fit
well obviously it's going to be a challenge
for me to
to ring fit quietly
oh wow
yeah brushy brushy brushy
I love that
a back massage
how do I back massage a stream
I mean I could literally in theory
do that back massage sound right now
like
hold on let me face the microphone
rotate a little bit
okay
my legs are gonna
well there's one foot I either say
your ear okay I know
I know
if you want a massage
wait hold on I need to reach for the oil
okay I got it
so this is oil
this is what massage ASMR sounds like
like literally that
that's it that's all I can do
sorry my feet are squeaking on the back
please don't fall
well my butt's pressed
on the floor
the bathtub
but this is it that's what massage is
it's good though oh is it hold on
let me put it on the other leg then
okay can I do this yet
can I do two things at once
hold my legs up in the air
and massage
yeah you like that
I like when you give me a massage
you should do it more often
button briefly
no you're not the bottom of the bathtub
mommy help me I'm drowning under your butt
but yeah this is massage
massage
a button massage
I mean that's when I get out of the bath
but I'm not out of the bath yet
I do have a few more tingles
wait hold on I need to bring my legs back
in the bath
and the other one
I think I have a few more things
more tools to use on you
the best days I could ask for
one you're a cephalopods
so you can breathe under water
two you love it
massage your feet
in all seriousness
pamper yourself spoiled strongy
you deserve it for pushing yourself
all this time
this honestly makes me smile
knowing that you are taking care of yourself
do those at the end okay
thank you everyone for your support
okay so I had
an ear picking tool
after your ears had been a bit
icky recently okay
so I can pick your ears
like this
because I know sometimes
when you listen to me for long periods
playing with the paper headphones you have
yeah
I'm gonna need you to
let me take out all the gunk in your ears
while I'm in the bath okay
is there a bluetooth ASMR
I would not trust it with my life
I hardly trust this microphone as it is okay
okay
one
it's okay you're allowed to have stinky ears
I just need to clean
I need to let me
did I not bring ear cleaner with me
that's like one of the first things
I always go to for ASMR
I don't have a freaking ear cleaner
hold on there's a cabinet behind you
it might have an ear cleaner
nope that's my razors
so I can
make some balls
and then
I have a toothbrush do you want a toothbrush
replacement
okay now I can't find the ear cleaner
I'm sorry I'm just gonna have to use this
ear pick
is this
fucking ear so far
I'm sorry it's fine I couldn't find
briefings have ears I thought we were
aquatic
don't start arguing with the lore
okay I'm the lore maker
don't you start piping up now
you're making me nervous
brush your teeth
you want a brush your teeth oh I don't have that
wait hold on
I'm going to do something very dangerous
I'm going to change my tracking
to right in front of me
if I
break my tracking because I've done this
you guys owe me big time
very big time if I break
my equipment because I've done this
you want to hear my heart
I'm going to have to lean out of the bath
I am not getting
I'm not bringing the microphone over the bath
just be careful not to hurt yourself
okay you want to hear my heart
the bath is slippery because
I put oil in it yep that's kind of how it works
I completely forgot
let me
rotate the microphone
and I'm now going to lean out the bath
I kid you not I'm going to go on my hands
on the floor in order to give you heart
a somewhat if I fall out
the bath you only 20 bucks
right hold on
oh god my legs are so slippy
I don't know if I can do this
wait hold on if I'm bringing
oh no
this is so terrible
hold on
I don't think I've done it right
get back in the bath
streamer it
it's so fast
did you hear it
bro your stress inflats your heart
yeah that's my heart it's always fast
I'm not a very
healthy person
oh did I have a massive delay
or was that just my
freaking laptop
never mind be safe
never mind be safe mama
is this the streamlining
or is it just my laptop
what are you doing
I'm celebrating 10,000 subscribers
if you form our food maker
I'm a little dismissive
in a bath of water
with a base more make
with a 10 meter cable
for each ear
her heart was so fast because she was scared
for her life
I have what is known as a naughty heart
and I was born
with it unfortunately
I can't do much about it
how much for the bath
should I do a
bath water giveaway
I'm gonna be honest the bath water
isn't clear okay so
if you're gonna get bath water it's gonna be nasty
okay I'm gonna turn down the ace marker
I'm gonna open up a can of cola okay
we have
you
you're bubbling all the bubble
to show you how much I was
pheromone maxing okay
all the bubbles in the bath are gone
that's how much pheromone maxing I did
okay hydrate with me refling
because we're not finished our bath routine yet
stinky wife
literally
pheromone
what on god screen is this
pheromone maxing
it's when
you're so pasty
okay
stormy's dad please come back
so she actually washes herself more
get me that fish stock
fish stock
how many glass jars I have
I unironically might do
fish stock and just straight up do a giveaway
if someone wants my bath
wait
donathan reward you get
fish stock
okay I'm gonna be honest
pure leaks about my
donathan in October
10th
I was gonna do
your choice of ink and apple juice
I could 100%
throw in fish stock as well
like if your donations like above
I don't know say a hundred dollars
you get a fish stock and a legit
do another bath stream
and it would be like collecting fish stock
after my donathan
that's disgusting
and I will do it I do not care
that's absolutely vile and I will do it
I'm gonna need four
ink yeah
it's the choice of apple juice
or ink for the top donators
and then
yeah
so either someone will figure out
I have really really stinky pee
oh apple juice
or you can add water
to the ink and do what you want with it
you will need to rehydrate
the ink if you do get sent to the
slightly saturated audio
I mean the microphones
very wet I'm not even gonna pretend otherwise
hold on
ASMR
an ASMR brush no this is a makeup brush
that's what they're actually used for
is this the left ear
I have no idea
what the microphone
is hearing in general
I think it may be just a
I don't know what ear is
oversaturated but there you go
that was the right ear
why did I actually
think apple juice you have too much faith in me
and
here you go
now do you guys want me to stay in the
bath for longer or do you want me to get
out, clap and oil up it's your choice
I'm not even
I'm not even playing right now
it's your choice
she really is your girl
clap and oil up
do you want me to get out
or do you want me to keep being in the bath
it's up to you
clap
more bathing
however we do bathing
for another what
a lot of people are saying oil
up to you
oil please
okay okay oil one
I am going to pull the plug
on the drain
oh no I won't it will be too late
okay what I'm going to do is
move the microphone over there
so I can actually get out of the bath
and I'm going to brew
my tracker over here
okay
I'm going to very carefully get out of this
damn bath because I've already got oil in my legs
right here
I'm out of the bath and just before anyone's
like clearly throwing in your feet
everything one fuck
you
okay
and then
I
was like I need to reach out
because I can't see it
no that stood up properly
okay
two
and three
what
okay let me put the microphone
I am going to
put you in front of me
okay so this is the oil
oil
that had reverb on it
okay so this is the oil
we're going to coconut ourselves
okay coconut
okay now we're going to get all over this
it's on our hands
I'm going to turn it around
I will read everything at the end
okay fine take the 20
that was peak lol
so we need to make sure
our peaches nice and hydrated
I'm trying to like
try to run so the tracker can still see my face
but it's not really working
so
okay
those were thunder claps
and then
we need to oil our leg
I'm oiling my whole body you're welcome
I'm oiling my legs
next because I only did
I didn't do the thighs
hold on I'm going to
I'm going to put a lot on the neck
so my both my legs are at either side of the neck
okay
oh my god
my clam is right in front of you
I'm kidding oh my clam is
right there this looks bizarre for my beauty
what here's my clam
okay
so those are my thighs
the claps make the thunder shower
oh your bd streamed on the 10th of October
it will yes it's my birthday
okay and then
we oil off our coconuts
and our tummies
because we need to be nice and smooth
it's okay
oh I need more oil
more oil
call me American because I need more oil
like hold on I'm going to crotch right in front of the microphone
I just realized there's so much taller
than you
I mean you need to
show the oil around
and just
just for proof
here this is proof
hear them
what do you think about this huh
what do you think that metallic
okay
no
do you guys want a round of applause
for keeping me company in the bath
do you want a round of applause
hmm
hold on
I'm going to try and
get my hands a bit less oily
I'm going to use the soap unfortunately
oil do you like that
okay
you're going to have to raid the bathroom
for all of that oil
I am American after all
are you steady
this is going to be very loud
okay
breathing
please tell me that was way
wait how many claps can I do
pair of trial are you ready
how many claps was that
I need a clap counter please
is anyone able to count the claps
send it
my goodness
I don't know
if anyone can count
it's like music to my ears I lost count
it was about over 20
right should I go for like
there hold on
I'm going to take a swig of cola
mommy you can't do this to me I'm not
working
what do you mean
I'm just clapping my hands
streamers aren't allowed to clap their hands anymore
what's going on
okay
y'all ready for this
I've had a sip of cola
I'm going to burp
and then next we're going to beat 30
okay
oh wait do you want to hear my heart
just before like oh my god
stroney you're faking it you're totally not moving
you're just clapping your hands
this is what my heart sounds like
okay
that's my heart
beat this record
okay
okay let's beat this record
we need to stare at you
okay
alright you know what
I'm going to put more oil
let's put more oil
actual hamster should I be the hamster
of each of her instead of a cuttlefish
I mean cuttlefish have three hearts
so honestly we'd be beating all the time
just a bit more oil
you hear that
my cake dropping
okay time to do clapping
ASMR smile
hamster alternative model
for gen 2
okay
theory we need to beat theory come on
we can do this
why did someone give me membership
while I'm doing this
okay I can't do anymore
I can't do anymore
why are you gifting membership
while I'm doing that
why did you do this
in the middle of that
okay I can't do anymore
okay we're under fire
oh
Vietnam flashbacks
that was 40
okay we did it
50 can we do 100
I can't feel like I want to do 100
I don't know if I have the stamina for it
I don't know clapping your hands
ASMR is really difficult
I will read all the gifts at the end
but thank you everyone for being so kind and generous
I'm going to take the microphone
into the room with me
so I can catch up on what I missed
okay
can we do 100
it was 79
no
79 counted
it was above 70
you should keep shooting higher and higher
if I do 100
I'm satisfied
if I do 100 I'm satisfied
that this stream has been nothing but a success
if I don't do 100
shame on all my family
hold up
little sipping to Nicola
again sip Nicola
give us a little energy burst
are you laughing
that was not 70
if you do 100 you get an achievement
literally there's going to be a gamer score pop-up
of like 100 claps per
I don't know effort
clap your hands
if you're happy and you know it clap your hands
real
I'm squeaking under the mat because there's so much water
on it right now
okay
I need to even if I get tired
I'm looking at myself in the mirror
and you will not stop
until you hear 100 claps mentally in your head
okay
okay we can
don't slip
if I slip this is a hard floor
so if I pass out and the stream is just dead silence
and we like breathing
I'm sure I'll be fine when I wake up but don't worry
okay
1000 claps let's go
wait hold on
I'm getting nervous now
I'm so tired
I can't do it
I'm trying
I don't know what that was
I'm so tired
I can't do anymore. I'm out of breath. What was that? I did it! Oh my god! Did I do it?
A, someone said A, someone said 120. Oh, we did it! We did it! You can't see it right now, but I'm spanked in the air.
VTuber does 100 claps per 10 minutes! Oh my gosh! That is insane!
How did we do that? Literally listen to my heart right now. I thought I wasn't going to be able to do it.
Can you hear it? I thought I wasn't going to be able to do it. Sorry, I wasn't supposed to be ASMR. Sorry, I thought I wasn't going to be able to do it.
Okay. Well, I'll work out, honestly. Can you do that live at a convention? What? You want to have one? Who gets paid to oil me up?
Oh my god, that's basebuses. Okay, reflames. I'm going to bring, actually, you know what? I'm just going to do it as I explain it.
I'm bringing the microphone into the stream room so that ambience is going to change, okay? Oh my god, I've covered an oil. How am I supposed to touch my keyboard a mouse?
Right, I'm going to very quickly bring the track and back with me, okay? I'm very, very quickly. Give me one second.
Okay, I'm literally right here. You can hear me enter the bathroom again because the apple is back.
Reflame, you're fine. Relax. Relax, Reflame. You're fine. You're safe. You're loved as I speak on the way out. Okay, don't worry.
Look, I'm back. Baby, baby, I'm back. Relax. Let me turn on the spacey. Wake up, Mr. P.
I've covered an oil. Okay, is the tracking working? Okay, tracking is working. I'm back in the room. You can hear it's different. Don't worry.
Don't worry, my little Reflame. You're okay. It's okay. You're fine. It's okay.
Okay, I'm going to go get a towel so I can sit on my chair without adding oil because there's enough liquids on this chair as it is.
It's fine. The bathroom's right here. Reflame is right here.
Okay, look at me. I've got it. I've got it. I've got the towel. I'm back in the room. Okay, shh, shh, shh, shh. I'm back.
I'm in the room. I'm putting a towel on the chair so I can sit down, okay? But I need to get you a towel because I didn't dry you off.
Hold on, hold on. You're fine, Reflame. I promise. You're fine.
What? What do you mean you're out of breath? Why would you be out of breath?
I don't know why I would be out of breath. Jeez. Maybe you're the one that's out of breath.
I only clapped with my hands ASMR. Okay, we're in the room. Go close the door so that there's no more echo, okay?
There's no more echo. Are you good to me right now?
Oh, it's okay.
Congratulations, Mama. You are starting to play for the first time.
Thank you. Praise the gesture.
Whoa. Where did that come from? Did you hear that? Where did that come from?
Wait, where's my cola? My cola. I can have it. Wait, I need my cola. I'm addicted.
I'm addicted and I just can't get enough. I just can't get enough.
Okay, ASMR. Shhh. Shhh, little Reflame. We're doing real ASMR. We absolutely aren't.
It's so cute. Wait, did I just? Oh, I just sat on your table. Sorry, I'm about to put oil on.
You're trying to dry you off. Okay, sorry. Sorry.
Oh boy, that was a stream and a half, wasn't I, Reflame?
Hold on, let me re-calibrate.
Okay, I re-calibrate.
Shhh. I couldn't see it earlier, but I counted 127 claps. Oh, yeah.
Okay, shhh. Calm down, little Reflame.
I'm going to dry you off, okay? Because we're at the bath now.
Let me dry you off.
Dry, dry, dry, dry.
This is one of those streams of wall time.
Do you think you can do karaoke up?
I usually get a room half as many claps before I get a mirror in there.
Do you want to know? You know why some women's coconut?
I think it's me.
Ascending? What? Wait, hold on. I need to, like, pop up olive.
I need to open up stream elements, but I need to open up YouTube's track-ins,
so I can say thank you to everyone.
Why am I hypnotizing?
No! Oh my god, I had to reset my models parameters.
My key bindings are back, because I had to reset my models parameters
in order to do the no t-shirt thing.
Okay, as long as the bubbles are still attached to my model, that's the most important thing.
I don't mean to hypnotize you right now, I'm sorry.
I completely, hold on. I think if I hit this button, that would be fine.
Hold on. Hold on.
No, it's all coming apart.
It's okay, really, don't panic.
I'm the only one that's allowed to panic here, because I've messed up terribly.
I'm so sorry. I don't mean to hypnotize you.
No, I'm hypnotizing even more.
Right, okay. I need to open up YouTube to look at any superchats,
and I need to open up stream elements.
Stop hypnotizing! I'm so stopped!
I promise I don't want to hypnotize you right now.
I'm hypnotizing you in the other ASMR stream that's coming up.
But not this one.
No shirt. I had to do it for the stream.
I couldn't be sitting in a bikini.
That's not how you do a bath, unless you bath with this stuff on.
But me personally, nah, I don't really...
Okay, I'm gonna go back and say thank you for all the superchats and stuff, okay?
And then I'm gonna go in YouTube and I'm gonna open up my earnings tab,
because that's for some reason how you access memberships
and people who've done nice things for you via membership.
Okay, shh. Friday and slip hypnotism.
Okay, once I stop having to click stuff, it'll be okay.
I promise it'll be okay.
How do I do this?
Memberships? See your memberships.
Okay, I think I can... okay.
Wait.
What?
Last updated.
Total what?
Oh no, this can't be. Okay, this doesn't look right, but...
I'll try my best.
Okay.
Show proof!
Okay, let me just stop hypnotizing you for a second.
No, stop hypnotizing more.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, let's do this.
I'm going to now go through all the thank yous, okay?
And then...
Don't panic, panic.
Did you enjoy that stream?
Was that like fun, crazy now?
Because I was good.
I actually do like the idea that ASMR ring fit stream.
I think that would be cute.
Yeah, that felt like RKO, so I'm not gonna lie.
I was like, I don't know what to do.
It was fun.
Aw, I'm glad.
Thank you for enjoying it.
Stop hypnotizing, it's not possible.
Okay, fine.
The best stream ever, not gonna lie.
The most unhinged.
Yes, thank you so much to everyone who's liked, subscribed, commented.
I like to celebrate Canada 5K Milestones, so...
Soon I will be doing a 15K celebration with thy cam.
Oh yeah, thank you.
Okay, we're gonna go thank everyone for being nice and supportive of me.
What the fuck?
Beryl gave $69.
An introduction might be effective way of stimulating the appetite of your...
...reeflings.
You have to be careful because...
...an errand glance at the serving tray may end with eating out the palm of your own hand.
What does that mean, Beryl?
Where were you saying?
Thank you, Kuhai, for becoming a member.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, Bobalix, for the extended membership.
We are on a tripod.
Yes, you are on a tripod.
You're still on the tripod.
You're actually beneath me.
You're at tummy level right now.
So if you want tummy sounds right now, yeah, you can get tummy sounds.
Cheers, I can't stay for long.
Thank you for the ASMR stream, mommy.
You're more than welcome, cheers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Lord of Storms, 20K reward could be a mud bath.
Oh, the sounds.
Wouldn't mud baths be really farty?
You want tummy sounds?
I recorded the full ASMR sound, so now I can fully make the pregnancy ASMR.
I hope you're excited.
You want tummy sounds?
Wait, hold on.
Oh, wait, you're on a tripod.
Does that make things more...
How do I really release you from this tripod?
Hold on.
It took me so long to set this up.
Can I even get you off the tripod?
What can?
You're off the tripod now.
Okay, mommy's holding you now, little darling.
This is my tummy covered in oil.
Okay.
Can you hear tummy sounds?
Yeah.
We were bubbling?
Yeah, that's the cola drink.
Okay.
Thank you, tiny spiny.
This stream really isn't that different from your normal streams.
Considering you said you should stream with nothing on TruReel
and absolutely no lies found.
You're just in the bath this time.
Yeah.
Doomsday done.
TTS on for ASMR.
Brian does not have an ethereal head to turn him down really quiet.
Thank you for the super chat.
You want to go in my womb?
I mean, this time tomorrow you might be in it.
You might be in my tummy.
Reluctantly sane.
Mommy, by the end of the stream we're going to be squeaky clean.
Only in body though.
Not in mind.
So pregnancy, ASMR is gender in the making?
No.
In October there's going to be an all audio
if I reach the goal of gender production
and I'm basically going to be begging you
to put a baby in me.
So do with that what you will.
Okay.
Little roofling.
Misaka best, the one time I was reincarnated as mommy's bathwater.
Wow.
Thank you for the tip.
Done, done.
If you insist.
A sleigh saver starting the bathwater bidding.
Oh, should I ask?
No.
We'll do it for a doughnathon.
I'm not taking my fish broth, okay?
There's too much fish broth.
Dips on the bathwater for 20s.
Spidey.
We'll do fish broth for a doughnathon, okay?
I'll take the soap bar for 100.
Jokes aside, congrats on Tanki.
Here's to a million.
Okay, done.
You really think I'm more than happy with that.
With any refill nutmases with me.
Like a million.
I think I'd be overwhelmed at a million, to be honest.
I like my reflux gatekeeping.
Wow.
I mean, I do it myself successfully.
Lord of Storms, you don't have to sin.
Just don't, just please don't drain it.
What, you want me to take a picture of the aftermath?
Want to put it on Twitter?
You want me to take a picture of the bathwater
that's literally not even transparent?
It's all cloudy and mingin,
because I used soap on myself and actually cleaned myself.
It looks like fucking milk in there.
It looks like milk.
The aftermath.
Well, because there's like oil everywhere, there's milk.
There's like ASMR tools in the bottom of the bathtub.
Like, it all went in.
Anonymous said,
in all seriousness, Trani, you deserve it.
You piss yourself all the time.
Aw, thank you.
This honestly makes me smile, knowing that you're taking care of yourself.
Splish splash, though I take in the bath.
Thank you, Anonymous.
Momo says, ayo, get me a liter of that water
bank's credit card on the car.
Oh, that meme where you're like, bang, bang, bang, bang.
I wouldn't recommend drinking it.
But you can have it if you want.
Broly legend, so what's the price?
There's no price, you goofy koopa.
You already know my favorite feature where I'm in love.
Is it because I'm wildly inappropriate and Autistic?
It's because I'm wildly inappropriate, isn't it?
Anonymous, uh, oh I read that one, sorry.
Basically whiz, if you follow it, please make a good splat or slap noise.
I'm very, thank you for the 20, I'm very glad I didn't splat,
because I could have really hurt myself now that I think about it.
Because the oil that was on my little knees were not that good.
You're the best, Ronnie.
Oh, you still making me blush.
Wait, you are making me blush.
Hold on a minute, I have a blush toggle.
You're making me blush, replay.
And then Broly legend says, never mind, just be safe.
Because I came out of the bath.
Reluctantly sane, okay fine, take this 20, that was pink, lol.
Oh no, what was that in relation to?
Was it the first clapping?
Oh my tummy's hungy, I need to feed my tummy.
Gonna have to raid Ronnie's bathroom for all that oil, I'm an American after all.
Okay, this must have been the oil section, thank you Kaidon.
Thank you, reluctantly sane.
You're the clapping, yeah, it's when you clap.
Or the first clap, yeah.
Sassapress, mommy, you can't do this to me, I'm still at work and my little tentacle can't handle it.
Oh no, you're listening at work.
Oh no, you better not do anything that'll get you in trouble with HR.
Thank you for the super chat, Sassapress.
Lord of Storms gifted five memberships, thank you.
Congrats to those who caught it with your face and thank you for the five gifted, thank you, thank you.
The next batch of emotes is coming soon, once Azura's emotes have been fixed.
Mercies have been delivered, so I need Azura's emotes fixed,
and then everyone can get their missing emotes, does that make sense?
But yeah, thank you because you're helping me get more emotes, thank you.
I love you, Viva.
Thank you for the bath stream, Ronnie.
It was truly one of the greatest stream I've experienced.
Love you so much.
I did not realize that Brian was super loud that entire time.
Well, thank god I'm a loud ASMRtist, let's be honest.
Okay, thank you for this super chat.
Oh, thank you for letting me steal your super chat cherry as well.
And I love you, Viva.
I didn't know, I thought that tip was literally someone being like,
oh yeah, Brian sounds so quiet because I purposely turned him down elsewhere,
but Brian comes out of two sources.
But I've been louder than Brian, so it doesn't matter.
Hey, why is he called Brian?
So the text-to-speech that you hear is actually Brian.
His name is Brian, that's what his thing is,
so if you look up text-to-speech Brian, it'll come up with that voice.
He's called Brian, maybe the guy was called Brian, I don't know.
Hello, Viva, thank you again.
I'm glad you enjoyed the stream experience.
Should I get a highlight clip of it? Maybe I should.
And thank you for letting me steal your super chat cherry.
Misako best, if you're happy and you know what, clap.
I mean, I could probably still do it right now, hold on.
Let me stand up.
I'm not gonna do it for long because my little heart can't take any more,
so I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, okay, yeah, I can do it at all times.
Viva!
I don't want to get too descriptive,
but the oil in between the peach
is making either cheek slide before the other one.
Does that make any sense?
I don't know.
I don't know if that makes any sense, either does.
But then I'm glad you like it.
Reluctantly sane, thank you for the super chat,
she went unlocked of thunderstruck.
Thick, thick is thickish dread.
Congrats, mommy, you're such a clap master.
Thank you, you're welcome.
I'm a visual learner, could you explain?
Slow, oh, I'm gonna cough, I'm so sorry.
There's a lot of coconut smell in this room.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I'm okay, there's just a lot of aroma going on in the room
and it's going for me.
It's because the coconut's very strong.
And I also recorded a teeny bit of ASMR before the stream,
which required massage oil.
And that had an aroma as well,
so I think my poor little, we can't hear you.
Yes you can, you're twirling me.
Okay.
Our Ragon, thank you for the super chat.
You know the way some women's coconuts coconutally.
I think Strani just created a new phrase for jumping
with cake, ascendingly assily.
This is pure cool, thank you, Ragon.
I appreciate it.
Feremon, Max, they're Strani versus all the perfumes, honestly.
And I love you so much too, little riflin.
I just called it that there, that I missed it.
And then for the memberships,
thank you, Gerald of Reverea.
That's that video game, I've still not played yet.
Lee Wink,
Culker,
Undead Roadkill,
James J. Dahl,
and Doctor Do Nothing.
That looks like everyone that joined today.
Thoustake Strim.
Oh here we go, Thoustake Strim.
Are you with the Sonic Fire 65?
Do, demo, pa, budding, gauge.
I don't know if it also counts as good, I don't know.
It looks very confusing, I'm so sorry.
It basically was, so fuckwin.
Right, I said you yesterday, I remember you.
Okay, I think that's everything, God, how we did that?
She definitely bit you with that.
Well, I'm dying.
Anonymous.
Anonymous says,
I was having such a do-do-dee dealing with people,
so I'm glad that you streamed as soon as I came off work.
Crazy, I'm more invested in a streamer
who's been doing this for two months now,
and for streamers who've been at it for years.
That's one thing, sometimes.
The mind craves new experiences and things, and that's okay.
That's why I'm never like upset if anyone wants to move on to the next streamer.
I don't get in solid or jealous,
I just want you to be able to relax and have a good time.
I mean, Anonymous, you literally said the very thing
that I think is important.
Have you had a rubbish day at the end of stream?
Yeah, I streamed.
Sorry.
If you have a rubbish day at the end of
what seems blown out,
hold on, I'm gonna adapt.
Okay, I've turned down the things a little bit.
If you have a rubbish day at the end of work
and you want to relax and chill,
then I say go for it.
And if I'm not the streamer that helps you de-stress,
then I want you to,
well, first I want you to try out the five other viola girls.
But if we're not for you, guess what?
I think you...
I think crawfish.
I'm not crawfish.
I'm a crawfish.
Don't call me a crawfish.
What the fuck?
Are you planning on cooking me?
You better not.
Bitch, stop!
Don't do that.
He's so silly.
You call him?
No.
Strongly 10% off-gamer subs.
Fuck it.
But for your luck, congrats on 10,000 subscribers.
Thank you so much.
I hope this celebratory stream was worth the wait
because it took me so long to be able to do it.
But there is a 15K thigh ASMR coming up.
So please don't look out for it.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
You're not sure about the cooking part,
but I'll definitely eat you.
I do what she be sometimes.
Oh, she's coming back though.
She is back home,
but she's not very well right now.
I don't know what's actually going on with Darling Shebe.
She's really feeling unwell,
which is such a shame.
Is Little Imig...
I don't...
No one's online for me to redirect into...
Oh dear.
Oh dear, oh dear.
And we're doing ASMR,
which makes it harder to redirect into literally anyone.
Oh dear, oh dear, oh dear.
Cutlery strongy.
Thank you for the correction.
You get one kiss.
For being so open-minded to being corrected.
Anonymous.
I subscribe to members to all the girls in Beale there.
You may not always be the ASMR stylist
I listen to when I go to sleep.
But you definitely stream my watch when I want to laugh.
You continue to be well and unhinged and all to sleep.
Oh, anonymous, thank you.
Yeah, I have to admit my ASMR is a bit...
Literally me who does ASMR stream,
also me who claps for like 120 times in a row.
We stream every day the moment I'm done from work.
It's so relaxing and rest my brain.
Yeah, I put like nice cold ice on your brain
after it feels like it's on fire from work.
Strongy, you can correct me whenever you want.
That's correct in time, really.
But it's okay.
I know you try your best.
Strongism is a final weapon you have to go against, yeah.
Yeah.
Are you allergic to cuttlefish?
Would you still lick me if you were allergic to me, be honest?
Okay, there's no one that I can redirect into that's doing ASMR, unfortunately.
So I think I'm just gonna redirect into Amy's stream
and you guys can wait a couple of hours for her to show up.
It's in three, it's in two and a half hours.
So yeah, you just wait two and a half hours for little Amy.
Okay, she'll be coming on set.
She's not coming on set.
Sorry.
Please correct us some more with some aggressives.
And whispering.
Refling.
You were wiggling around in that bath and it was so hard to clean you.
You know it makes it harder for me to do what I need to do.
So do you need punishment?
Oh, it's oil.
I'm eating coconut oil.
I put it against my chest.
Sorry, there's oil in my mouth right now.
I forgot about that.
I need to clean the microphone.
I just put oil in my mouth.
Well, I think I'm gonna gag.
Well, I'm gonna drink some cola because that was not supposed to happen.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm good, I'm good.
Okay, it's okay.
Just for the folks at home, please do not put oil in your mouth.
Okay, it's fine.
Perfect way to end an ASMR stream, real and true.
Okay, I'm gonna go clean up because the aroma of everything that's on me right now is making me gag.
And I've just put it in my mouth.
Thank you so so much, Reflings.
I love and absolutely adore you and thank you for anyone who gives any of Veiler a chance,
if that's me or my gen mates.
If I'm not for you, please check the links in the description to my gen mates.
They might be much more your speed.
Thank you so much for any likes, any comments, any subscriptions.
Don't be afraid to subscribe because guess what?
We're already doing a 15k ASMR celebration.
It's coming soon.
And then for 20k subscribers.
So 15k is in real life thycam ASMR.
And then 20k is ring fit for one hour ASMR.
It's as quiet as I can so it's probably all breathing.
And then I get a shower and I'll bring you into the shower with me, deal?
So yeah, thank you everyone who supports me.
I'm gonna redirect you into any silent room, okay?
So don't worry about it.
And for those who are a member, I have a karaoke stream that's going up in 30 minutes, okay?
So I'll see you in 30 minutes once I'm all clean and not oily.
Thank you so so much for hanging in.
I'll see you good figures later, okay?